I just truly don't feel like doing my
hair today judge me come at me bro
specifically my brother Tim what do you
got to say about this hair hi guys it's
learning this great topic if you did not
know now you know your life is different
now you know this video because you've
read the title or you clicked on the
extremely subtle Asia's thumbnail that
will likely be associated with this it's
probably like this that's a good
thumbnail if it's the end of September
so it's time for September favorites
let's get right into it what does this
look like Axl Rose prep school girl okay
first yeah get the actor yeah yeah say
yeah I think we'd add to my special
skills spelunking because I cave
I got a Kylie lip kit in fact I got
three Kylie lip kits and here's the deal
I don't even know if these are my
favorites I got them yesterday I
immediately tried all of them on and I
liked all of them they smell like a
variety of sugars you know I love a good
stain both on my clothes and my mouth so
these really they work really well it's
a toss-up of which one is actually my
favorite but I'm wearing this one right
now so I just put this in this is called
dirty peach there's also just the
dumbest greatest name usually make up
names are always like weirdly overtly
sexual or there's some sort of pun this
is dirty peach the peach emoji is the
butt so what we're talking about dirty
butt holes is that what this is supposed
to remind me of whatever I think of like
a dirty peach like a peach is just been
rolling on the ground cover it in muck I
want to put it right on my mouth this is
a favorite not only for the name but for
it itself I have it on my lips right now
and I know a lot of people said it's
really drying I don't notice that it's
super drying on my mouth likely because
I'm wildly dehydrated and my lips are
super chapped anyway so makes no
difference to me
next yeah yes the idea si si si yeah
this is two-faced bronze and poreless is
that a pun Oh young and the restless'
bronzed and poreless either way it's a
bronzer from two-faced and look at
like that and I like it and here's the
fun part I also have acquired a two-face
bonds Buki brush it's basically a brush
that you apply this bronzer with but I
ordered this slightly intoxicated so I
cannot remember if this came with the
bronzer or if I bought this separately
either way both of these are great that
has no odor I don't know why it smelled
it I don't know why I just smelled it
next yes yes yeah yeah say yeah yeah say
yeah these are BR I's free yo pores 30
daily deep pore cleansing cloths I love
these because I am lazy and washing my
face I do it infrequently but washing my
face is always a big ordeal and I splash
water everywhere like my roots get wet
and let me think it's like gross good
this is such a terrible thing to
complain about these are basically like
toner wipes I think they're not makeup
wipes I learned this the hard way I
tried to wipe off mascara and burn my
eyes for like five minutes straight
I immediately reverted to like my high
school biology class like get to the eye
wash station don't do that don't put
these near your eyes but these are great
wipes to just sort of cleanse your face
if you use a makeup wipe it doesn't
really like cleanse it sort of takes the
makeup off and I'm always left with some
sort of like filmy feeling after and so
this if you follow up with this kind of
like you don't like in hockey when they
have the UM what is that thing called
Zamboni the shoe Zamboni yeah this is
like a Zamboni for your face I feel like
great endorsement not sponsored never
will be now maxie yes yes hey Emily I
think these are some leopard print boots
from Topshop and I am in love with them
I have romantic human feelings for them
in like a healthy way
they're like mohair so they feel like
animals on your feet which is great but
I just feel like and I feel like animal
from the Muppets constantly so very own
brand and they're really comfortable the
heel is probably like 3 and
but they're really comfortable I am
spent the last year-and-a-half looking
for leopard boots that work cute that I
liked and I could not find any last year
and I saw these on top shop comm and I
immediately ordered them look at these
these boots were made for stocking
because I wear them when I get real deep
into some instagram-stalking and it's
just a really stylish unhealthy time
next yeah yeah say yeah yeah say yeah
say yeah say yeah this is a pillow with
a picture of some of my family on it so
my birthday is tomorrow Tuesday the 27th
and I like to give my family a lot of
personalized gifts I have put my face on
a lot of domesticated items and gifted
that to them for Christmases and
birthdays and things like that and this
time around my dad and stepmom gifted me
this pillow it has a picture of my dad
my stepmom my younger brother Tim me my
step-brother Mike I'm my older brother
John and it's on the pillow and it's so
good get it good looking look at that
nothing has changed thank you dad and
stepmom marine this is a really lovely
gift and I love it so much next yeah yes
yeah yes yeah yeah hey yeah actually can
you see it oh it's a ring this is a
birthday gift from my mother and my
stepfather I saw them in New York they
came to the it's pre advanced screening
of dirty 30 in New York City and they
gave me this ring my mom and I have
gotten more into like tarot cards and
crystals and things like that lately and
so she found this ring but apparently
all of the stones on it represent
different chakras in our bodies and if
you wear it a certain way it opens up
your chakras and it's just supposed to
be good for your aura and that's sort of
like you know that kind of stuff that I
like make fun of me all you want but I
like the kind of stuff and I thought
this thing was so pretty and thoughtful
so thank you mother
and Bill my stepfather also it makes my
pointing at people less aggressive next
yes the yeah yeah say yeah yeah say yes
this
to be the dumbest thing i've ever
included in the favorites but I just had
to this is toilet paper but it's not
just any kind of toilet paper I didn't
order this on purpose I went on Amazon I
ordered some toilet paper because I was
running out and this showed up and I was
like how did I not see that this is what
I ordered it's toilet paper without a
tube in the middle no - Toulouse toilet
paper you - let's store the paper is
this scotch or the paper something like
that I don't know but I was like whoa
that seems wildly unnecessary in the
advancements of toilet paper and then
I've been using it and it's great
because when you're done it just
disappears there's no tube to refill you
just put your toilet paper thing right
on it and then it's gone there's
something so wildly dumb about that and
I love it and it makes me imagine what
like the pitch meeting for this product
must have been like and how serious it
had to be and like just working for a
toilet paper company in general seems
like so dumb but there were humans that
do that and like also through any toilet
paper companies out there that would
like to sponsor me I would love that
this has all just been one long con guys
one long con next do you see if you see
if you see you can't see it if you
download that 3030 this is a ticket to
the dirty thirty premiere that happened
in Los Angeles last week dirty thirty
our new movie the Hannah a memory and I
are in and we've been promoting like
crazy over the last few weeks is out you
can download it on iTunes on my birthday
tomorrow it'll be in DVD form in target
- just crazy and I kinda want to make a
video running around to a bunch of
targets and trying to sign any of them
that I see in target so maybe that'll
happen we are so proud of it and we're
so happy that you finally get to watch
it and we just really want you to watch
it I love this movie the night it came
out i juat drunk in my hotel room in New
York and I watched it three times so
someone called that narcissism I call it
just undying support I hope that you
guys check that out if you haven't
already all the links for all of it will
be in my description below so yay
also inside know
it'd be a really cool birthday gift if
you guys download it dirty I am NOT
above leveraging my birthday in order to
guilt you into downloading my movie
that's it for September favorites if you
guys like this video don't forget to
subscribe to my youtube channel and give
this video a thumbs up let me know in
the comments down below so your favorite
moment in 3030 without any spoilers if
you could that would be very you don't
respectful I don't know look at Tim it
gets better it gets better I think these
are transition lenses in his glasses too
so